This week, we will continue
our discussion of energy.
We will introduce the
concept of potential energy--
which is related to the work
done by a conservative force,
and also the concept of
total mechanical energy--
which is defined as the sum
of the kinetic and potential
energies.
We will demonstrate that
the total mechanical energy
of a system remains constant
if only conservative forces are
acting.
This is known as the
Principle of Conservation
of Mechanical Energy.
We will also see
how the work done
by any non-conservative
forces causes
the total mechanical
energy of the system
to change, usually causing
mechanical energy to be
lost from the system.
Finally, we will see how graphs
of a system's potential energy,
as a function of
position, provide
an elegant way of
understanding the behavior
of the system for a given value
of the total mechanical energy.